gordon ramsay who is used to making
chefs lives a living hell
but now he has found a new recipe to
roast wannabe cooks on social media
young lady that there is an idiot
sandwich
ramen cheese on toast forget it i'd like
to ram that somewhere
let's go big boy yeah it's basically
hell's kitchen on tick tock with gordon
skewing home cooks
who dare to use the hashtag ramsayreacts
trust me i'll be the judge of whether
you
are an idiot savage or not i'd rather
eat one of your plastic nails
even gordon's own kids aren't immune to
his savage culinary critiques
here's what happened when 20 year old
daughter holly made one of her dad's
recipes
young lady you should know better shame
on you holly
it's just been a a chef's dream come
true no stop it cook out the flour you
donut
disgusting but if you think that you can
stand the heat in gordon's kitchen
we can tell you from experience you
better bring your cooking a game
45 seconds to go use a spoon lady use a
spoon
of course it's hot in the kitchen kevin
can you speed up please
you're about as fast as my granddad he's
dead come on
oh my god take the apron off
and while the 53 year old dad of five
including 16 month old little oscar
is having a lot of fun with friends and
family on tick tock juice
sauce but how does it taste thank you oh
boy
jason dorito
there's one person who's not at all
impressed wife tauna
what is the one thing that you've
learned about your husband being around
so much
he doesn't realize that when you cook a
meal
you have to clear up oh
oh my god the mess it's not just the
mess but it's like
he'll make something and there's like
this sheen of oil
over the entire kitchen oscar's shouting
you come in now oscar